the realm do you know what the realm is
it's the thousand blades of Aegon's
enemies a story we agreed to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another game of Thrones update
video in this video I want to discuss
some of the recent news surrounding the
Game of Thrones successor show as you
all know HBO has been creating another
new show that is based on the asana
bison fire universe they originally
wanted to have five different shows in
development but as of right now only one
of them was greenlit to begin casting
various actors and even begin filming at
first we were told the new show would be
titled the long night then we heard it
might be titled Blood Moon but
regardless of the name we do know the
new show will be set roughly five
thousand years ago right around the time
the White Walkers were created that is
according to the show's description now
if you have seen some of my other videos
or stay up-to-date with any and
everything Game of Thrones related then
you would know they have been filming
the pilot episode for several weeks at
the very least many of the actors we're
already seen around Northern Ireland
which is where the Game of Thrones main
headquarters is located and some of the
set photos have already been circulating
the internet well some new information
has been revealed thanks to one of the
bosses over at HBO
during an interview Casey Bowie said
they did finish the filming for the new
pilot episode he also said it looks
really good and the actors were amazing
so far so good
now we're certainly not out of the woods
just yet but this is a relief because
sometimes things start breaking down
before they can even finish the filming
sometimes there can be serious issues
with either the writers or actors or
even the director but it sounds like
things went relatively smoothly for the
first episode now I'm not exactly sure
how the entire process goes but I think
once everything else is done with the
episode some of the bosses over at HBO
will watch it then decide if it should
get made into a full season or not this
is actually where Dan and Dave ran into
some major issues when they handed in
their first episode for Game of Thrones
they ended up having to get different
actors rewrite some of the scenes and
obviously film new scenes as well
dan and Dave were actually lucky they
were given a second chance because based
on all the accounts it does sound like
it was a disaster but they obviously
remade the first episode and the rest is
history so even if they do run into some
issues with their new show they might be
willing to give it another chance since
it worked out so well with Game of
Thrones what was a disaster ended up
becoming one of the most successful
shows in television history now all we
can really do is hope for the best
I know I'm still very optimistic about
the news show I believe it can do very
well since it will have a lot of the
same ingredients that made millions of
fans fall in love with Game of Thrones
if any other information is released I
will inform you as soon as possible I
figured I would just make a short update
video to let you know that they are done
filming the first episode
anyways feel free to leave me some of
your own thoughts down below I want to
thank everyone for stopping by to watch
the video and I want to thank everyone
for supporting the channel I hope you
all have a great day and I will see you
again very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
you